okay so this lecture is in a way a whole
linear algebra
course uh created by highlighting five
different ways that a matrix gets
factored by by factored I mean a a fact
factorization would be the first example
will be a matrix a every Matrix a
factors into a matrix c and a matrix r c
times R and I'll describe those um and
uh so the and later ones involve igen
values they involve singular values it's
it's linear algebra in a nutshell of
these
factorizations so this is uh coming from
from the latest and the final edition of
my linear algebra book I'm grateful to
say there's a six Edition this year
2023 okay for the start let me start
right out with some of the key ideas
before you see the first factorization
so one key idea is whether a set of
vectors is linearly independent or
dependent and that simply mean dependent
simply means that some combination of
those vectors gives the zero Vector of
course I'm not allowing the zero
combination which takes zero of every
Vector but some other combination like
two of the first Vector plus three of
the second Vector minus 11 of the third
Vector gives the zero Vector that would
mean those vectors were
dependent okay and combination
combinations is what you can do to
vectors you take combinations M multiply
them by numbers X1 X2 X3 multi they
multiply the vectors A1 A2 A3 and then
you add
those those together
so every time I teach theolog this is in
the first lecture how do you multiply or
how and how do you think of a matrix a
times a vector X and I think of it not
as a lot of little tiny computations dot
products but I think of it vector- wise
I think of a * X as a combination of The
Columns of the Matrix and uh we'll come
back to that that's important okay and
now that third line is speaking about C
* R so those are matrices now we're
multiplying a matrix by a Matrix before
it was a matrix times a vector so I'll
have to show
you important ideas because there are
several ways to multiply a matrix by a
matrix and they're all important it's a
fantastic subject and one example would
be every Matrix will get factored this
will be factorization number one every
Matrix a will get factored into a into a
matrix C that just comes from the
columns and a times a matrix r that
comes from the rows which you will see
soon okay oh I even wrote it at the top
number one a equals CR but I'm going to
leave the details the all important
details for the coming slides I thought
here I would tell you uh factorization
number two because it's probably the
most used factorization in numerical
Computing probably billions of dollars a
year are spent in taking a this is
usually a square Matrix a and we're
trying to
solve n equations in N unknowns where n
could be
10,000 and the way to do it is a
factorization uh and it's known as Lu
everybody connects to to that those
words Lu l is for lower and U is for
upper and those are used because the two
matrices L is a lower triangular Matrix
above the diagonal of the Matrix is all
zero all the nonzero parts of the Matrix
L are
below whereas U is the
opposite it's zero below the diagonal
and it's nonzeros are all on the
diagonal or above
so virtually all matrices factor into a
lower triangular times an upper
triangular sometimes you need a matrix P
of permutation you'll see permutations
show up here once in a while that's just
a reordering of the rows sometimes if
the rows start with if the first row
starts with a zero you're not happy with
that and you have have to switch switch
rows okay so and why is why is this L *
U so great well because you can solve ax
equals B let's say solve a set of
equations by first solving the problem
with the Matrix U and then yeah let me
it's it's so we're going to solve it in
two steps as the as the slide says the
first step is to
solve find the solution ution to l c
equal B so so L is lower triangular B is
the right hand side we want and C is the
answer to that you could say it's half
the problem it's the lower triangular
half of the problem so that gives us an
answer C that's not the x that we're
that we're finally aiming for but it's
halfway and then put that c on the right
side of the second equation = C now
we're solving for x with the upper
triangular part you see the two
triangular matrices and triangular
systems are fast to solve and that's why
it's just fantastic to split the Matrix
into two fast fast cases and then when
you put them together a * X is a is L so
we have Lu * X and the ux is C so we
have LC and that was B so we got ax
equal B okay that every course is going
to teach that I don't have to I won't
say more about that but of course it's
fundamental so I'm going to go back to
this c times R which is not so classical
but I think it's a great way to start
linear algebra okay okay here here's an
N examples always the best okay so you
see a matrix a you see has three columns
1 2 1 1 3 4 376 three
columns uh so and it has three rows so
it happens to be a 3X3 Square Matrix and
it it's small enough that we can find
the C and the R so listen up because
this is what this is the key point so
what's the Matrix C C is for columns so
you see that I took took the First
Column and the second column of a and
put them into c 1 12 1 and 134 I did not
take the third column in C and why not
because it's dependent that column
376 is a combination of the others so
what do I mean by a combination I mean
that two of the First Column would be
242 and then if I add on one of the
second column 134 I think that 242 and
134 add up to
376 so in a way 376 is already there in
the first two and and and that's
reflected in the in the r in the in the
r Matrix the the the one that's more
horizontal that has row emphasizes the
rows so do you
see here we're seeing it how matrices m
multiply so uh so you see the Matrix C
with two columns and I'm multiplying by
The Matrix r that has two rows and let's
look at the third column of R what do we
see in the third column of R we see the
two and the one that's exactly what we
wanted to get the third column of a so
I'll just say again columns one and two
of a were inde dependent no they go in
different directions so they go straight
into the Matrix C independent columns go
in C but R is aimed to catch up with the
columns like the third column of a that
are combinations and again you see why
it's two and one because two of the
First Column plus one of the second
column that combination of independent
columns gives the dependent column ha so
and if I jump to the bottom line uh that
Matrix r that that row Matrix starts
with the identity does everybody know
about the identity matrix it's it's the
it's the equivalent of one for matrices
if you multiply by the identity you get
the you get whatever back again so the
identity is that one Z Z1 part and then
the F part
is the is the part that reflects the
dependent guy the third column 2 one so
I so my point is going to be that every
Matrix I can pick out the independent
columns put them in C and then R will
tell me what combinations of those
independent columns gives all the
columns so so here here's the
mathematical truth of this of this thing
so we have I'm going to use the letter
little r for the for for the count of
how many indpendent columns so R was two
before uh the N minus r or the other
columns the dependent ones so what my
the factorization is that every Matrix a
factors into C * R where C contains the
independent columns and r has these sort
of two or three pieces so R has the
identity do you see r r is the if with a
p so so three three matrices are are are
involved with r the identity Matrix
because when C multiplies the identity
Matrix it just gives those independent
columns in C nothing the identity
doesn't do anything the i c * X F that's
the combinations that give the dependent
columns and this uh Matrix uh P I'm
tempted to say this damn Matrix P the
permutation just if the columns came in
a crazy order or a different order
instead of it's it's super nice when the
independent ones all come first and then
the dependent ones all come last that's
what we saw in the example but here but
there's an example at the bottom where
the can you pick out the independent
columns in The Matrix on the the 1 two 3
4 1 two 4 five Matrix so the First
Column is independent it's fine but the
second column is just two times the
first so that second column is
dependent and then we get an independent
column 34 that's a new Direction and
then we get four five which which is
dependent again so this had two
independent columns the 1 one and the 34
and you see them sitting in C and then
you have the r Matrix that tells you how
much of each independent column do you
need to get every column of a so and and
there's if you want the identity Matrix
to come first that's what a permutation
does it switches the order of the of the
columns and so it puts that identity
Matrix the one z01 Matrix first every
Matrix factors into C * R and C is the
independent columns and R has this
special form it's famous as the row
reduced Echelon form whatever okay so
onwards so yeah now here are the
facts see has I'm using little r for the
count of independent
columns it turns out the Matrix R has
that many
rows then and then a is equal to C * r c
* R so there's matrix multiplication is
Central here uh so and the C has oh and
now I've introduced a new word the
column space so we have a
matrix what's the column space let me go
back to a matrix and talk about the
column space how about the column space
of that of that Matrix a that we Now
understand pretty well the column space
is all combinations of the
columns
so I would say the column space of that
Matrix is all combinations of the first
two columns because the third is already
a combination so I don't have to include
it in the
basis the good word is the basis for the
column space if I'm wanting all the
independent columns if I'm wanting all
the columns I really just need the
independent ones because the others are
combinations so the column space c is
the is a plane here it's the combination
of just two vectors and the row space r
is also a plane it's the combination of
two rows combinations of two rows so we
have a column space space is a big word
and it means take all the combinations
of the of your of your basis vectors and
so let me go forward to the great first
theorem of linearalgebra it's so this
gave me pleasure I have to admit that
it's at that last line the column space
of a matrix remember our Matrix had two
independent
columns and the row space so that Matrix
has two independent
rows that's mathematics is telling me
that from AAL C * R all rows of a are
combinations of rows of R this you'll
have to think about these ideas and the
and the first
uh and and work some problems finding
CNR and seeing this wonderful fact if
you had a matrix that was 50 rows and
columns then it would not be clear for
without a big computer how many rows are
independent and how many columns are
independent but the truth will be that
those two numbers are the same if it has
11 independent rows it's got 11
independent
columns for me that's just a wonderful
fact so that's that's the first great
fact and and now here's the big picture
of column space so we are really moving
along here we are moving so these boxes
these four boxes are filled with vectors
so we call them Vector
spaces so and I'll describe what what
that that word space is important okay
so what is the row space that's all the
all the rows and all combinations of the
rows that makes the row space you get a
space by starting with some vectors
taking all their combinations it fills
out the plane it fills out three some
three-dimensional space it fills out
some R dimensional
space let me just ask you just let's
just take it suppose I have two vectors
in three
dimensions two independent vectors in
three dimensions like as in my example
there uh two independent vectors in
three dimensions so I'm in 3D I'm in
three-dimensional space and I take all
combinations of those two independent
vectors and what do I get I get a
plane that goes through Z 0 because one
possible combination is
z0 and it's a nice FL plane in
3D that's that's you can visualize that
that a Bas it's the dimension of the
plane is two because it took two vectors
to give you everything you needed to
know about the plane take all
combinations of those two vectors so we
had a two-dimensional plane inside
threedimensional
Space what what about the
columns same same idea you start with
the columns you take all their
combinations so that's the column space
again the space means take all
combinations so it's a whole it's I've
drawn it as a as a square or rectangle
or a box uh it's a it's it's filled in
by taking all
combinations it it gives me a plane it
gives me a three-dimensional Subspace
well if I have a bigger Matrix like a
10x10 Matrix
then the row then I might have six
independent columns the column space of
this 10 of this Matrix would be all
combinations of those six independent
columns that they they would each all
those we we're sitting inside
10-dimensional
Space just just visualize 10-dimensional
space or don't visualize it I can't but
anyway if you can do it so and in that
vect in that space the 10-dimensional
space is some Thin very thin part of it
which has only six independent vectors
so a six-dimensional column space inside
the big 10-dimensional
space okay so the the first our first
great theorem was that the number of
independent
rows equals the number of independent
columns for every Matrix that that's
just wonderful so that means that the
size of the row space and the size of
the column space is the same and then
the other two guys the null spaces are
the solutions to axal Z so ax equals z
says some combination of columns or of
rows is giving zero and so that this is
accounting for the rest so we had like
six dimensional row space inside 10
dimensional space then the null space
which I'll come back to but the point is
it will be four dimensional so that six
and four make 10 the the the whole
10-dimensional Space is is being split
into the independent rows and the null
space on one side and the independent
columns and the null space of oh you see
this symbol a transpose a transpose just
means reverse the rows and with the
columns if if I have a matrix a with 10
rows and eight columns then a transpose
will be the other way around eight rows
and 10 columns oh well this is a whole
linear algebra course but we're we're
moving I have to tell you a little bit
how you would find which columns are
independent and which are not it's an
algorithm how would we how would a
computer find the independent rows we
have to be able to answer that question
because for big matrices we need the
computer okay so uh yeah the it you
remember we're it's interesting that the
computer would look first for are the
row Matrix where where I introduced
first of all C The Columns the
independent columns well it finds them
both at the same time this this
algorithm it just progresses column by
column across the Matrix column by
column we go across the Matrix and we
ask is this new column say column k + 1
is it a combination of those previous K
columns or is it independent that's the
key question if it's a combination of
the other ones then it'll go in with the
F part if it's independent of the first
ones it'll be a new independent one and
it'll go it'll the I the identity Matrix
will grow by one so I I I'm not going
to push you to follow the steps of the
of this
elimination well actually they
elimination was invented in China three
or four thousand years ago so it's it's
fundamental idea it's just subtract a
multiple of one row from another row to
get a zero in a place where you want a
zero you we can understand what's going
on when we have when our Matrix has
enough well-placed zeros so so elimin
mination is just subtracting rows from
other rows to produce Zer in the right
position so we can see what's going
on all right here we here we're actually
going to use elimination and see and the
idea of null space and idea of equations
so this is this we can do this we can
do so over at the top left you see uh
three equations
and you see four unknowns X1 X2 X3 X4 so
we have a
3x4 matrix and it's a full Matrix it
hasn't got any zeros and the idea of
elimination is to get some zeros into
that Matrix in fact we can see where
those arrows are showing what where we
want to go so so we're starting with the
Matrix a 3x4 matrix with these numbers
279 11
3748 are those columns independent or
not elimination will tell us okay and we
want to know which rows are
independent uh so I'm I'm just going to
look at that those numbers at the top
for a little while but well I I'll go
halfway down just to sh share the the
nice math
notation so so I wrote the equations at
the top but really I wasted a lot of
time writing in all those plus signs and
equal signs and and so on uh really it's
the numbers that count so you s you see
the numbers 1 2 11 17 in the first row
so they go in the first row of the
Matrix I just skip all the plus signs
and X1 x2s I know know they're there
it's the numbers that matter and then we
have
our we we get by elimination to this
much simpler form r with the Matrix
R uh now let's see maybe we could do
some of these in our head I think that
if I add equation one to equation two I
get equation
three do you do you agree with me if I
add take I'm at the top top left of the
of the of the slide if I add X1 to 3x1 I
get
4x1 and if I add 11 x3s to 37 x3s I get
48 x3s of course I cooked it up this way
so if I instead of adding if I sub If I
subtract the first equation from the
third and I subtract the second equation
from the third then I have nothing left
that equation becomes 0 equals 0 that
tells me that really really this Matrix
this big Matrix a has only two
independent rows that that that I'm are
sitting there in R do you see that you
see R the the the long the last Matrix
the
one35 that comes from the first equation
after elimination and the 01 4 6 those
are the coefficients of X1 X2 X3 X4 in
the second equation and I didn't even
bother to write the 0 equal 0 equation
because I don't need don't need it or
want it in r r gets rid of all the Z
equals zero
stuff so where are we we started with a
matrix a well we started with four
equations and the the numbers in those
equations went into a and I did
elimination I did m i sub subtracted 3 *
Row one from row two and that knocked
out the
3x1 and so forth so I ended up with the
equations on the right which went into R
the
one35 and the 0146 you see as predicted
we start with the identity Matrix in R
the
one01 and then we have the other stuff
the dependent coming from the dependent
stuff and we started with the first two
columns in in C 134 279 those are
original first two columns and we didn't
have the third column or the fourth
column because those are combinations of
the first two so this is a matrix of
rank two it has two independent Columns
of first two and it's got two
independent rows which are I could
choose the first two rows of a or better
the first two rows of R what the the
whole point of this was to be able to
solve RX equals z and the when I when
I've got or ax equals z is the same as
RX equals z now and R is this simple
Matrix so do you see that that Vector
minus three down where it's talking
about the null space null means zero so
these two vectors there they solve RX
equal Z and therefore they solve a xal z
that that's what you're looking for in
Solutions of equations if you took that
Min -3 - 4 one0 Vector those th those
are X1 and X2 and X3 and X4 they easily
solve our our simplified equations at
the top so all together we have done
what professors assigned students to do
for centuries of linear algebra we have
solved equations by elimination we had
some messy equations we took
combinations of those to give some nice
equations then we solve those nice
equations and we could express the
result as these two vectors at the
bottom or but we could express the whole
elimination as C * R the two independent
Columns of a times the two rows of
R oh th this was like I this is my final
slide on this first factorization then I
I'm not going to give such detail on the
later
factorizations because the textbook and
the and your professor know those so
well I I just want to say here that uh
matrices really using
matrices in in Matrix algebra is is
wonderful and one of the things you can
do is to break them into smaller
matrices so you see that
whj K well that's that's our big Matrix
with four
submatrices in it and W is the part of
the Matrix that's coming from
independent columns so that arrow in the
Top Line says the W moves to the
identity that's that was the theme of
all those crazy computations we did was
to make that top left corner into the
identity and then it makes the rest of
the Matrix into what you see
that but just to say that if you think
of
elimination by blocks instead of just
single numbers then you see the big
picture the big picture but the the the
the real picture was done on that slide
slide at the top that's where we did the
elimination and and then we got the
piece the nice pieces that we we're
seeing
here okay so F that was all
factorization one a equals CR because
you need some help with
that that's that's brought up so many of
the key ideas and tools of linear
algebra go into a equals CR and it's
just
wonderful okay so now oh I'm seeing the
word
orthogonal so this next
factorization is takes a matrix a and it
The Columns of a are probably not
perpendicular to each other all all the
examples we had The Columns of a if I
looked at the angle between them it
wasn't 90
Dees they there's a simple test for
perpendicular that called The Dot
product and it
matrices
usually vectors don't don't pass that
test they're not perpendicular but it's
wonderful when they
do perpendicular vectors are super easy
to compute with orthogonal is just
another word for perpendicular so and
it's a shorter word and a more used word
okay
so what's the idea of this
factorization again we take any Matrix a
and we're going to get it into two
factors but they're not going to be L
and U anymore they're not going to be C
and R they're going to be Q *
R and Q is this new
idea this new idea of perpendicular
vectors I just want to say that
perpendicular vectors are so easy to
compute with it's it's if if independent
vectors are good perpendicular vectors
are super independent because they're
going in 90 degree directions and look
to see the nice equation that you get if
you have these perpendicular vectors so
I'll use that letter Q little little Q
so do you see where I'm multiplying a
matrix Q transpose times Q in the middle
that that matrix multiplication so Q The
Columns of Q are our orthogonal vectors
and I adjust their length to be one
that's no problem so they're
perpendicular and their lengths are one
and Q transpose well so transpose is a
operation that we use a lot it just
changes the rows the columns into rows
so the columns were q1 to
qn in in in the second factor and then
the first Factor we change q1 to q1
transpose which is a row so so we have
now n columns perpendicular vectors in Q
and we have n rows that are
perpendicular vectors in Q transpose
that T is for short for transpose and
the whole point is that when I multiply
those two matrices Q transpose time Q
that's when
the perpendicular stuff pays off because
q1 transpose times Q2 is zero
perpendicular vectors they're when you
multiply them or a row times a column if
they're perpendicular you get zero so we
actually get the identity Matrix from Q
transpose times Q so that means Q is a
well Q is one is for me
uh well I'll say the queens of linear
algebra I'm not making them the Kings
but the queens of you of linear algebra
are these matrices whose columns
are length
one and perpendicular to each other uh
but this is a important idea that if I
start with a bunch of independent
vectors they're going in different
directions no combination is zero then I
can turn Bend turn those vectors by a
matrix R so that they are not just going
in different directions they're going in
90° perpendicular
directions it's it's just terrific to
have vectors that are perpendicular so
that's actually factorization three is
is doing it to The Columns of a and then
factorizations four and five are doing
it
to uh you'll see factorizations four and
five are the great achievements of
linear
algebra so I promised you five
factorizations and we've got three two
to go and they're actually together here
they're they'll take time in in the
course and and uh so one is about igen
values every Professor wants to explain
igen values those are nice igen values
and IG
vectors and the other one is about what
are called singular values and singular
vectors not so famous except for the
fact that they are the best of all that
so I'll try to compare them so you'll
see how they're related because I can
values are sort of simpler to see but
singular values are important too okay
so so let's suppose we have uh it's nice
if the Matrix is symmetric s so s for a
symmetric Matrix that means that if I
flip it across the diagonal it's still
the same so the number that's in the
bottom left is also in the top right now
here's the key idea igen values and igen
vector factors of that Matrix S so the
big equation is s * x equal number
Lambda time x SX equal Lambda x what
does that mean that means that x a v x
is a vector s is a known Matrix known
symmetric Matrix and I'm looking for
vectors
X which don't change
direction when you multiply them by S
they don't change direction previously
we might have been looking for vectors
that go to zero SX equals z not now we
have the key equation you'll see in that
Top Line is s *
x equals a number Lambda time x so it's
still in the direction of X its length
just got changed by that factor Lambda
so and that Lambda is called the igen
value X is the igen vector igen is a
sort of German prefix that is everybody
uses here yeah so so SX equal Lambda X
you will study that type of question
it's how do you find the x's and the
lambdas in a way the problem is
nonlinear because Lambda is multiplying
X so it's it's not like SX equal b a
right hand side SX equal Lambda X takes
new ideas and you'll see them okay and
the beautiful thing is that when s is a
symmetric
Matrix then these igen vectors these X's
it turns out that they they're
perpendicular to each other and so if I
stay on the left side of the screen
which is about s you'll see that
SX if I if I use Matrix notation s times
I can list all the igen vectors there
are n of them
luckily so same size as s If I multiply
s times those igen vectors I get those
ion vectors back again times that
diagonal matrix of lambdas which are
just numbers so SX equals x Lambda
that's the factorization four well I can
put the X on the far right and write
write it differently as s = x Lambda X
inverse a matrix a symmetric Matrix X is
its IG Vector Matrix x times its
diagonal IG value Matrix Lambda times
the inverse of X that so it's a
factorizations it's got three matrices
in it now okay that you're going to
learn about those guys that that's this
this is the the second half of the
course the first half of the course was
elimination spaces of vectors A x equals
z linear equations now we are
deeper with igen vectors and with
singular vectors and singular values now
what do those mean the point is that
every Matrix doesn't have to be square
doesn't have to be symmetric every
Matrix a has a full set of singular
values and what are and vectors s
singular vectors are really more
important than the value the the numbers
the values are those numbers Sigma or
Lambda that scale things it's the
vectors that are
great we we'll always take the vectors
to be length one and then the scaling
goes into the sigma or Lambda okay so
what are what's the deal with singular
values
I'm I'm now telling you
about number five factorization five the
the the end
of a linear algebra course TP frequently
or in the past courses didn't get as far
as singular values but you got to push
to get there because it's so important
it's become more important oh it's hard
to say this more important than igen
values well it's closely so closely
related that you but you just have
to singular vectors apply even when the
Matrix is
rectangular and uh they apply to every
Matrix so they are exceptional and what
is the main point of singular vectors
listen up because this is
it every
Matrix
a has you can find a bunch of of
perpendicular vectors inputs V1 V2 up to
VR the rank the number of independent
vectors so so
orthogonal orthogonal vectors going in
V's multiply by a and orthogonal vectors
come
out not for ION vectors they come out in
the same direction for other atries
that's too much that you can't expect
them the same direction but the amazing
miraculous thing is that you can there
are orthogonal vectors going in if you
pick the right orthogonal perpendicular
vectors going in then the and multiply
by a then perpendicular vectors come out
so so so sing these are singular vectors
that a matrix
takes orthog one orthogonal bunch of you
could say in
in uh orthogonal one set of orthogonal
vectors in the row space multiplies
produces orthogonal vectors U yeah so so
that also is a matrix
factorization but if I and and the
famous one is the one halfway down the
page on the far right a equal U Matrix
times this diagonal Sigma Matrix times
the V transpose the outputs oh no sorry
the v's are the inputs because being on
the right they're going to hit they're
going to hit them a new Vector the first
so if I multiply by
x i I hit them with v or V
transpose that rotates the space then
comes then I hit them with Sigma this
diagonal matrix that just stretches the
thing and then I rotate again isn't that
amazing every every Matrix is a product
of a
rotation a a diagonal stretching Matrix
and another rotation well you know what
it means to rotate a plane just you know
rotate a plane through an angle if
you're an airline pilot you know what
about you know about rotation in 3D what
are those yaw one of them there are
three rotations that an airplane can do
uh in the same plane either horizontal
plane or vertical plane one angle if we
have just
a in in a plane the rotation just takes
one angle in in three-dimensional space
it takes three angles in
four-dimensional space well that's
for linear out alra course so that so
what what are we saying what does this
this singular value stuff tell me it
says again that for every Matrix I can
find perpendicular vectors for inputs
and when I multiply the The Matrix the
outputs are perpendicular too that's
what it says that's what it says
perpendicular inputs that give
perpendicular outputs they're very
special normally that won't happen but
there is a set
of perpendicular inputs where the
outputs are perpendicular and I'm going
to show you that or try to in in 2D in
2D so I'm looking I'm I'm thinking I
have a m a 2X two
Matrix and my vectors V and W are the
usual one Z and 01 so If I multiply them
by this Matrix so they're perpendicular
all right V is perpendicular to W no
problem if I multiply by my Matrix I get
a * V and a * W well the odds are a
million to one that they're not perent
here I didn't I can't expect so much
luck that the may maybe if the Matrix
was a diagonal matrix or some simple guy
then AV and aw would be perpendicular
but generally they won't be so V and W
are not the pair that I'm the input pair
that I'm looking for okay let me make
one more try and fail again I'm going to
try uh to put in W and minus
V so I'm looking at the middle picture
now I'm looking at the middle picture
I'm I'm multiplying
W by a so that still gives me the a W
and I'm multiplying minus V by a so it
comes
out like 180 degrees around from the
original AV in the first picture is a
minus V in the second picture if you
think you need to think about it this is
a little bit of a
proof so what's the point well this new
pair W and minus V didn't didn't work
either the angle was not 90° after I
multiplied by a and that's what I'm
shooting for okay but here's the little
idea small idea the the angle in the
first case was smaller than
90° when when I multiplied by a the AV
and the aw had some small angle Theta
between them but now if I multiply W and
minus V by a I get a big big angle
bigger than 90° and Mathematics steps
into the into the problem here in
looking for an idea and Mathematics says
that
somewhere
between the VW that I started with and
the minus and the W minus V the second
pair somewhere there's a little V and a
little W that get then make it right
because it was AV was too close to aw in
the first picture they were too far
apart in the second picture but as I if
I go smoothly around I'll go I'll hit a
point where they're exactly right and
that's what the third picture is telling
me so there's a proof that that every 2x
two Matrix this is a two-dimensional
proof that every 2x two Matrix
has a pair Little V Little W which are
perpendicular and then also a * V and a
* W are perpendicular yeah so that's
factorization five and that's my that's
if you cover that in in linear algebra
course you're doing well but I have
despite the fact that that slide is
numbered 12 out of 12 there's another
slide that doesn't have a number
okay if you're up for this this is about
deep learning so if you if you want to a
job eventually probably most people
would like to have a job then a lot of
jobs we know are coming from Deep
learning so I I was I would tell you
like a little bit
of this is the last chapter in the
linear algebra book it's probably not
part of the linear algebra course
officially
but why not learn about deep learning uh
artificial
AI what's what is what what is deep
learning well deep learning starts with
some training data some inputs with
known
outputs so I'll call the inputs U1 U2 u3
I maybe have maybe have a thousand in
known
inputs and a thousand known own
outputs I've got a lot of information
from the training data and then I want
to be able to predict for a new input
you not one of these known ones not part
of the training data but a new guy what
is the
output so I I going to assume that the
the relationship which I'm never going
to know the relationship is something
reasonable that that if I if I have a if
my new input is near to one of the U's
the near the the output will be near to
one of the W's but it'll be affected by
all the other U's and W's so it's it's
called interpolation or something I'm
looking for a function that fits the
data and then I can use that function
for new data test data where I don't
know the output
okay that's that's the thing and now I
want to tell you the key idea of deep
learning the the question is what kind
of a function are we going to choose
we're we're going to it'll have some
freed so that we can make it fit the
known training data we can create there
are a lot of there are zillion ways I
could create a function that was correct
on the known data that gave me the right
answers W from the inputs U what I want
is to be good on data that I haven't
seen and that was the important problem
important scientific problem that has
been largely solved and understood much
better but there's more to understand
still by uh deep learning okay so I'm
just gonna
go quickly here the question is what
kind what what kind of function should
we have what kind of function should we
should I try one big Matrix well
matrices are
linear and and I don't know any reason
why this this unknown function should be
linear so matrices are going to come in
there but also some nonlinear stuff has
to come in and it turns out do you
remember the chain rule from calculus
it's it's the it's a cool rule out of
calculus that if what a chain of
functions you you take a first you take
an input give it input in a function F1
you take that output put it into F2 take
that output put it into F3 there a chain
of chain of simple functions is a is a
good idea it you quickly can build up
quite a quite array of interesting
functions out of very simple ones and
now comes the very last slide uh to tell
you the particular functions that deep
learning uses the particular functions
that deep that so people tried
linear they they multi the function the
function a k times the input plus some
Vector
BK like a straight line as ax plus b so
so the first
attempts
were had linear stuff well how can I
teach linear algebra and and have to
confess here that linear is a limitation
a big limitation and it was too much and
and a good linear
interpolation doesn't there isn't one
you've got to make something nonlinear
and and here's the crazy thing the fact
that has surprised everybody that that
this a particular nonlinear function
that everybody calls Ru
Ru that's a not that's a particular
function that zero for when the input is
negative and it gives back the input y
when Y is positive so it's so the graph
of the function is two straight lines
horizontal line line below zero 45
degree line above zero that's Ru so
that's a nonlinear function just of a of
a number the input is a
number tell me so what is Ru of minus 7
if I input minus 7 the ra of minus 7 is
zero what is RA of plus seven seven so I
get zero or seven when I input minus 7
or seven okay that's the that's the
magic function anyway the idea is to use
that nonlinear function in every one of
these simple fs and then you put all
these Fs in a chain and then you find
these matrices A and
B that are the that are the substantial
part of the function and it's ajust
giant calculation which we are not going
to do here but it's a
success this this idea has created
functions it may not be the only way to
do it I would like to say I would like
to Hope and think that there could be
from this one we could learn the learn
what's important and find other ways of
creating a functions but this
combination of a chain of very simple
functions
each of those simple functions involves
linear Matrix a and a vector B and then
this rayu thing that's nonlinear thing
that knocks out the negative part and
then go on to the next function onto the
next function and choose the good A and
B to fit your data and then uh you've
got a way to predict the output for new
in inputs and uh that's what so many
problems are about if if you know some
training inputs and outputs how do you
predict the output from a new and
different input well that's what deep
learning does and I hope this last
couple of slides which are which
represent the final chapter of the sixth
edition of introduction to linear
algebra
um and I could uh
yeah a lot of people email me to about
the books or about linear algebra and uh
that's makes my life interesting too
thank
you